Collin your character Harry is the
epitome of the gentleman's five
how does Harry combine sophistication
and mind-boggling fighting skills with a
good director and a good writer it's you
know I think that it's one of the things
I acted
sometimes polarizes into two different
things you can do with it one is that
it's it's a mask where you can pretend
to be the things you want to be it's you
you go in the direction of your fantasy
it sometimes can be where you go to do
worst fears and bare yourself at your
most vulnerable and weakest and that's
your least appealing but this was
definitely the fantasy side of things
you know somebody had written a role
dress me up in the suit
give me the dialogue to write it to do
and a brilliant team of stunt guys
basically all there just to make me look
good
Sophie can you describe the relationship
with your character Roxy and eggsy yeah
I think Roxy is obviously the odd one
out because she's had to start one of
the only girls and therefore immediately
discriminated against and although she
comes from the same social backgrounds
as a lot of the other guys she's
ultimately the weaker candidate because
Kingsman is still quite an old-fashioned
Institute and then eggsy turns up who
she sees is kind of devil definitely not
what she'd expect Kings or the others
would expect Kingsman material to be and
through their apparent weaknesses even
though they don't see it as weakness
they form an allegiance together and and
yet and ultimately they just don't I
don't like the other candidates and they
they support each other through that and
they're there for each other
it is platonic come there and they're
mates and eggsy doesn't just serious
someone gorgeous you know what it did
just you recognizes that she has
integrity and that she's a lovely person
and that she's fierce and strong and
able and capable
and they kind of both just bond over the
fact that they're not Terran what jars
eggsy to undergo the rigorous Kingsman
training well I think he's kind of you
know feels a bit sort of lost as bits of
disenfranchised and hairy this kind of
very Grammatik kind of hero figure shows
up and probably in some way particularly
with the connection with his father
neatly steps into that absent dad role
and offers in this opportunity to do
something constructive with his life
annuities a very very capable young man
you know he's said to have about average
IQ and you know he's got all these kind
of natural physical skills and this is
the sort of perfect outlook for them and
what is heresy and eggsy that makes him
think that he's in Kingsman material he
knows a lot about him he knew his father
and there's an emotional involvement
because his father died heroically
saving harry's life and it was due to a
mistaken Harry made so there's an
immense emotional investment in that and
so I think he he sees him as having to
take on something of the father
responsibilities but he also who's been
watching this boy grow up from a
distance and he sees this enormous
talent an enormous potential and he also
sees him going down a path as he says
which is going to end badly and I think
he sees a very very troubled boy with a
troubled family and he wants to because
he owes it to the boy to to save him
from that and he also thinks he's the
right material he's been through the
Marines who's competed and you know
youth gymnastics competition can you all
discuss Matthew Vaughn's vision for the
film and what specifically about it
caught your interest
well if he said ugly his own you know I
think he's this is paradox in message
the way I said there's a mixture of
childlike love for cinema I mean it's
something almost completely pure just
the fan the the kid who just wants to be
enchanted and spellbound and have his
mind blown by Wolfe extraordinary things
on the screen it's as pure as that on
the other side is something very very
sophisticated a real you know a very
very mature cinematic and worldly
informed Sensibility so he knows how to
conjure with all that and that's I don't
think it's not always you can get that
at high functioning level in the same
person what's your favorite comic turned
film franchise I think brilliant I do I
love those comics when I was a little
boy and I had all the sort of duvet
covers and post other things and I think
it's just I just think it's really
elegant the way that they've you know
started with the old cast brought in
this these you know the the new
generation with Fassbender and James
McAvoy in Compton Florence you know
doing the earlier part of the story and
I just think it all works great with the
timelines and he's pretty clever and
funny and entertaining because that's
kind of what I I grew up with and I
remember seeing it on TV is when that
being curious where it all came from and
and then yeah there are incredible films
yeah definitely no Terran can you
describe the relationship between eggsy
and harry yeah well I think you know
Titus was slightly touched on it earlier
didn't I I think cam it's a kind of you
know Harry feels whether you know
rightly or wrongly that he let down my
dad during the opening sequence when he
sacrifices himself to save Merlin and
I'm Jack Davenport's character Lance
rotten and hairy and you know cut for 17
years later and things haven't gone well
from XE you know he's got a real nasty
piece of work living with him and his
mom his mom having been a very very very
sort of together you know well presented
but not not dysfunctional lady has
turned into a real really quite
dysfunctional person you know seems to
be sort of just really down on her luck
so there's a big gap in eggsy's life for
someone to come along and and say you
know buck your ideas up one and offer an
avenue for for him to sort of do
something good with his life so I think
in a kind of weird way in you know they
kind of it yeah they've kind of it's a
sort of father-son a sort of thing I
think
you